Just like that, I end up standing in front of someone who's with the gable
I hate it,
but now that Kirishima-san isn't around, it's a great chance Can I have
dinner next to you today
Oh, oh, oh,
oh  ]
Mosei:
No, Ojoumoto doesn't talk, so I'm going to have to start talking about it.
Recently, there have been fun things at school.
Oops
,
I'm going to rely on Kiritsubasa, won't you come over to my room after you eat?
You should be able to do
it, so this is the
Hohoumi-chan series. Maybe it's a
gentle rabbit theory, but it's
powered up with the power of big brother carrots
.
Far from getting excited together, instead of getting excited together, I'm more into it than Daimasu, I'm more into it, and I'm more into
luxury,
Chokkoro Hill There are
tissues, Sumiba
Zero
[Music]
I'm always like this Even if I
watch a
movie with Mr.  Thoughts on seeing
art Kirishima Well, it's rare,
so I can't see it unless it's a work that ends in one piece like a movie
.
sir
[music]